[Music]
[Applause]
brian greece espn monday night football
analyst and uh monday night football
kicking off september 13th that'll be
the ravens and the raiders on the
mothership with steve levy lewis riddick
brian greasy
brian's foundation by the way judy's
house helps children who have lost a
parent or a sibling and it's been around
for more than 15 years broke ground on a
new facility
judy's house for grieving children and
families find out more at judy's
house.org
brian how are you today
good morning dan i'm doing great how are
you how do you do
um with twitter
how to does twitter is it in your life
uh
no i would say it's it's not much uh a
part of my life i i do use it to get
news in a timely fashion but um
you know in this in this industry it's
hard to
go back and forth on that medium it's
it's a it's a tough one so i avoid it
for the most part
you ended up at michigan but you grew up
in miami was was your dad with the
dolphins at the time and that's how you
ended up you were there in miami and
then how'd you end up in michigan
yeah it's uh you know my dad went to
purdue and uh he was really um hoping
that i would go to purdue i wasn't very
highly recruited dan out of high school
i think
i think i had two or three scholarship
offers one of which was purdue and i
told my dad i said
uh dad it's a great school but i don't
want to be an engineer
which purdue is known for engineering
um so i'm gonna walk on at michigan so
uh not only
am i not gonna go to your alma mater and
get my education paid for i'm gonna go
to arrival and you're gonna have to pay
for it
where were you on the depth chart who
was ahead of you at michigan
uh i think i was sixth or seventh on the
depth chart uh you know back then
uh there there were guys elvis gerbach
had just left todd collins uh jay
riemersma who ended up being a tight end
in the nfl with the bills
um you had jason carr i mean i could
the other quarterback who was a
scholarship quarterback was scott
leffler uh you know tom brady wasn't
there yet that was two years later but
ended up having to compete with him as
well
uh but it was a process it took me three
or four years to even sniff the field
what did you know about brady so you're
junior brady comes in
were you nervous about losing your job
uh i was always fighting you know to
keep my job uh the year before tom came
in uh they signed the number one overall
recruit in the country ended up being
scott dreisbach who played as a freshman
and went on and played for the raiders
um so every year it was you know
top three or four quarterback in the
country so
uh when tom came in and just looking at
tom the way he looked at the long hair
he's from california and you know he's
not the greatest athlete in the world uh
it wasn't like everybody was oh my gosh
this is the next guy
um ultimately
so uh you know it was uh it was an
experience for me to to battle and to
have to to earn my my playing time there
for sure okay but what is it though
because brady shows up
same thing when he went to the combine
like nobody did anything nobody went wow
oh my god you got to see this guy so
what is it about brady that separates
him from anybody who's played this
position
yeah dan if i had to sum it up in in
kind of one
sentence it would be he he's willing to
sacrifice
more than anybody else
and that sacrifice could be a number of
different things right his diet his time
um
his body i i think
i think that that's what that's what
differentiates him and he does start
from scratch every single year when he
comes to training camp he feels like he
hasn't accomplished anything and that
mindset that mentality that
competitiveness and that that
willingness to sacrifice
if i had to sum it all up that's what
makes him different he's not out there
you know looking for for other things to
do outside of football until he retires
um and who knows when he's going to
retire i think
i i think he could have his best year
this year it's all lined up for him
with the team the the the pieces that
are back uh the organization and so i
there's no reason for him to stop
playing until he's not enjoying it
anymore and i would say he's enjoying it
more than he ever has can you teach what
brady has
i don't think so no
uh i think it has to be earned uh i
think it has to be learned
and you know he learned that
through difficult experiences i mean uh
it was not an easy journey for him in
michigan
um people forget that that he
he probably should have been the
starting quarterback but he was forced
to split time with with drew henson
and he had to earn everything he got and
he constantly heard that he wasn't fast
enough he wasn't
big enough didn't have a big enough arm
all those things and that was ingrained
in him and he kept that
and so i think it's it's experiential
for him i don't think that's something
that's innate
he's brian griese espn monday night
football analyst former nfl quarterback
you got a chance to see the saints and
the jags let me start with the saints
what is sean payton waiting for in
naming his starting quarterback
yeah we spent about an hour and a half
with sean uh this past weekend and
honestly dan i think he's genuinely
conflicted or at least he was when we
had the conversation before the game
um i think that he has so much respect
as he should for taysom hill and what he
has done for this team what he
sacrificed for the team what he means to
the team that um that he wanted to be
intentional about creating a level
playing field for this competition um
and and i think he he tried as best he
could to do that now
we talked with taysom as well
and taysom understands that there is a
value that he brings to this team to
this offense outside of the quarterback
position that potentially could weigh
against him uh in the evaluation uh and
i think that everybody understood that
but but sean was trying to create a
level playing field and i think that's
why this took so long and
taysom hill in the past seven to ten
days in camp really has played well and
has gotten the coaches attention
so i think if you would ask sean after
the first two weeks of camp i think in
his mind he would have been saying it
was it was jameis and then the third
week at camp uh taysom came on uh and
then what happened on monday night you
know jameis could not have played better
not just with the way he threw the ball
but with the way he executed and ran the
offense and made checks at the line of
scrimmage and so
i think that i think the decision has
probably been made at this point after
watching monday night uh and i would
expect sean to come forward with that
you trust jameis winston
i trust jameis winston
under sean payton
i think that sean payton is one of the
best quarterback coaches uh in the
league um i think that jameis obviously
we know he has
the physical talent uh we know that he's
uh that he wants it i think he's been
humbled
uh and i think that he understands that
it's not necessarily about him but it's
about this this team and and that he
doesn't have to be superman every time
he walks out on the field uh but that he
needs to execute and i think he's
learned from drew brees i mean there
could not have been a better
situation for jameis to come into and
watch for a year and to learn from drew
and and to not lose jameis's
aggressiveness and ability to throw the
ball down the field which we saw monday
night
but to incorporate more of the
underneath checkdowns and understanding
situational football keeping the team
moving protect the ball you got a good
defense
um so i i trust jamis in that system in
tampa
with dirk cutter and bruce ahrens and
people that wanted to push the ball down
the field and didn't get backs out
didn't allow him to check the ball down
all the time listen there were a lot of
dirty hands in those 30 interceptions it
wasn't just jameis
so i expect to see a different
quarterback this season for the saints
urban meyer know what he's getting into
urban meyer is a smart smart guy smart
coach been around he has not been around
the nfl i'll give you that
but i think he understands what he's
getting into
i don't know that he understands the
level of competition on a weekend and
week out basis and how hard that's going
to be
and i think that it's a 1-15 football
team
i know urban's never been a part of that
um so
with a rookie quarterback and and a
franchise that's trying to redefine
itself
and on top of all of that
they're trying to crash these two
forms of offense together
one an nfl offense with daryl bevel and
what he's done throughout his career in
minnesota and seattle and then you bring
in urban's ideas of the spread offense
from college that he
has some non-negotiables that they they
want to incorporate into the offense
so how they mesh those two things
together
in front of an offensive line that's
that's not very good
that's not a great recipe and and and
then how does urban handle the losing on
a week in a week out basis that's
there's a lot of question marks there
well in trevor lawrence trevor has lost
a total of four games in his high school
and college career combined he's going
to lose that by you know the end of
october probably
do you think that there's a chance
jacksonville would go with gardner
minshew to start the season
because
that offensive line is not very good
um and almost let trevor kind of ease
into it dip his toe into it as opposed
to going into the deep end of the pool
i do
um and i know that that probably doesn't
sound right the number one overall draft
pick uh not starting week one
but if you know urban meyer he
the one thing he doesn't care about what
the fans think he doesn't care about
what the media thinks uh he's gonna make
the decision that's best for trevor
lawrence
um and you know i i don't think that
this has been about competition
obviously trevor lawrence is going to be
the quarterback for the jaguars when
that happens is the question and i think
you're exactly right we talked about
this monday night they don't have an
offensive line to protect trevor
lawrence as it stands right now
um so
one of the things that urban mentioned
to us when we talked this past weekend
is he talks to his old quarterback joe
burrell from ohio state he was his
quarterback he called him right when
they drafted trevor lawrence and he said
listen what can i do to protect this kid
you know and we saw what happened with
joe in cincinnati
uh he said listen you have to
run the ball and get the ball out fast
those are the two things that joe said
and urban says i'm going to call joe
once a week every week to kind of learn
from him how is his experience as a
rookie first overall pick and and what
can we do to support that so it's not in
urban's mind he's trying to do the right
thing by trevor lawrence and and i i
don't disagree with him if he starts
gardener minchi week one uh that's going
to be about protection
better arm elway or mahomes
wow
um
that's a tough one uh you know
i i watched john elway up close uh my
rookie season and
he did some things that i had never seen
before
um
patrick is more creative and innovative
uh with the arm angles and off platform
throws and that john
they were i've never seen anybody that
when he got his feet set and he stepped
into something i have never seen anybody
throw the harder harder ball than him
patrick i think can can throw it further
off platform and not need his feet
but but i still think that john elway
could he had a howitzer man it was it
was unbelievable to watch
and elway was probably 36 37 at the time
when you joined the team
yes i mean and i i would watch film of
him in his early years and you're right
i mean
uh the drive you know some of the throws
that he that he would make
in tight windows down the field um i i
just i've never seen that before now
josh allen has a little bit more of that
i think when he gets his feet set
uh the down the field driving throws
um that looks a little bit more like
elway i liken mahomes to steph curry i
think he is to quarterbacks what steph
curry is to shooters now that doesn't
mean mahomes will be the greatest
quarterback of all time but i think what
we're seeing with him
you're probably going to have a lot of
quarterbacks well we've seen this
already
they're emulating this just like steph
curry trying to emulate every you know
your kids out there in you know
fifth grade are trying to shoot like
steph curry quarterbacks are going to be
trying to throw like patrick mahomes do
you do you agree with that parallel yeah
all right so it's funny you know my
son's 12 and he's you know we're
throwing the ball out there and i'm
trying you know
i have the prototypical emotion i'm
trying to you know elbow up you know to
see up here and all this i'm trying to
teach him the proper mechanics just like
my dad 30 years ago taught me you know
and he's out here arms like sideways and
his feet aren't set he's running this
plane
i'm like oh my gosh
does your son have a better arm than you
it's um
look at zach wilson i mean zach wilson
is doing some of that that stuff so
listen it it it takes an unbelievable
athlete to do that but i think kids will
be
experimenting more um and offenses will
be experimenting more and so i think
you're gonna see more and more of that
style of play coming up from high school
to college and then ultimately to the
nfl
your son have a better arm than you
oh
listen i had a little bit better arm
than my dad you know my dad had zonka
kick mercury morris you know he he
didn't have to you know air the ball
down the field so i had a little bit
better and now now my son yeah he's he's
definitely gonna have a better arm than
me mike my daughter has a better army
[Laughter]
when did you realize your dad was famous
uh
gosh i used to go to training camp um
and i you know i'd go out there and and
you'd have manny fernandez you know and
larry little and these guys that back
then they were big you know manny
fernandez only like 260 pounds playing
defensive tackle that that wouldn't fly
anymore but to me back then
uh going to camp
he let me sit in the in the cold tub and
the hot tub after practice with the guys
and just listen to the banter and just
the respect they had for my dad back
then that's probably the first memory
that i had of my dad you know being the
quarterback for the miami dolphins and
sitting in a meeting room with don
schula for for the quarterbacks to watch
film i still remember those days and
so it was pretty early on that i know
that my dad was hot stuff
gosh you're in there with don shula and
shula shula's could be tough like you
know he was no nonsense and i
i can't imagine your dad he's probably
saying be quiet just sit there
you know don't say anything you're
probably squirming around like little
you know boys do
yes i'm in the back you know back of the
room and i used to sit you know with the
they had a legendary uh equipment
manager bobby lamonica uh uh who's back
he always used to send me home with
shoes and stuff for uh for football
practice and whatnot but i sat in the
back and i just you know i couldn't say
anything uh but but just just listening
to some of the stories they tell stories
and and how schulich no
so it's interesting you bring this up
because next year dan 2022 is the 50th
anniversary of the undefeated season
and uh unfortunately we've lost coach
schuller and
you know jake scott passed away recently
and and you know bonna connie's gone and
langer and there's a lot of of those
great players who are no longer with us
but um but i'm i'm fired up excited
about the 50th anniversary of that team
and getting them back together and some
hearing some of the old stories and
hopefully we get a chance for you know
the rest of people that love football to
hear some of the great stories of that
season i think it's a great opportunity
to celebrate them
you wear your super bowl ring
no i do not um you know i uh
i was a rookie dan and i threw three
passes that season uh one was a
completion for two yards one was an
incompletion and one was an interception
so i
i don't i don't wear that ring
very often
is it there in the room
no it's in my sock drawer you know
now i'm going to have to move it because
everybody oh now they know
if you want to find greasy super bowl
ring it's in the sock drawer hey great
to talk to you uh have fun with the
season coming up there it'll be uh week
one ravens and the raiders in las vegas
thank you brian great to talk to you
again yeah dan good to catch up anytime
that's brian griese he'll be on the call
there with louis riddick steve levy
monday night football